is Kiri one with ediwa well the Tolkien
abandon their pacifist ways is there a
future of a spider and quarriage there
is still so much story to tell at the
end of Avatar the way of water
perhaps the biggest question in all of
Avatar the way of water is the one posed
in the opening narration who is kiri's
Father Jake Sully tells us that after
the death of Dr Grace Augustine in the
first film they discovered a child
growing in the body of her comatose
Avatar that child Kiri is adopted by the
sullies upon her birth but her actual
origin remains a huge mystery throughout
the film numerous characters including
Kyrie herself speculates as to who her
father might be there are so few
compelling answers that even Norm is
mentioned as a possible candidate in
reality no one has any idea who the
father could be given that Curie has
strange and Powerful abilities and Feels
So Close to the natural world of Pandora
that she can hear a was heartbeat it's
possible that the whole father question
is a giant red herring when Grace dies
the navi were trying to move her soul
permanently out of a Dying human body
and into her Avatar the process failed
but before she passed Grace told Jake
that awar was real sometime afterward
the pregnancy was discovered could Curie
be a creation of AWA herself the
All-Seeing goddess of Pandora it's very
possible while Grace's Soul was too weak
to survive a transfer into a ravatar
perhaps AWA was able to put a child in
her instead that would explain the
unknown father kiri's powers and why
Sigourney Weaver plays both her and
Grace for now though we'll just have to
wait and see
I know you think I'm crazy
but I feel her one of the most
interesting new characters and Avatar
the way of water is spider he was a
human baby left behind on Pandora when
the RDA was sent home and as we're told
multiple times throughout the movie you
can't put a baby in cryo sleep while
there are a few other humans around for
spiders upbringing he prefers the
company of the navi like Kiri he becomes
a member of the Sully family he tries to
fit in the best he can by adopting the
dressing customs of the amitakaya at
times he even paints himself blue
perhaps the most interesting thing about
spider however is that he's the son of
the villainous Colonel quarrej this
causes a good deal of drama when spider
is captured by quoridge and his cronies
but we never learn about his mother
since spider was just a baby when the
humans were sent back to Earth he would
have been born on Pandora shortly before
the events of the original film that
means that his mother would have been
part of the RDA crew so where is she was
she sent back to Earth with the rest of
the RDA and what was the nature of her
relationship with courage for now at
least those questions remain unanswered
at the start of Avatar the way of water
the sullies are still living with the
amitakaya in the forest that tyria
stepped up into her late father's role
as a Clan's protector and her mother
moat remains their spiritual leader the
community is torn asunder however and
courage returns with a squad of Avatar
Hitman all of whom have been sent to
wipe the sullies out we don't get to
spend that long with the omatakaya
before Jake and his family leave to join
the met kaina and after their departure
we never go back this leaves the fate of
the clan completely uncertain though
there are some Clues as to what might be
going on back in the forest but told
early on that the Clan's Mountain
Hideaway is inaccessible to ordinary
humans quoridge can sneak in because
he's in an avatar so with him and his
Squad hunting Jake the Oma Takaya should
be pretty safe this theory is further
supported by Norm's visit later in the
film since he's still stationed with the
Alma Takaya in the forest you'd think
you'd mention if anything truly terrible
were happening of course the main RDA
force is still on the omotakaya's
doorstep General odd Morris prepping for
full colonization of the planet and the
hunt for the unobtanium is presumably
still active with all that brewing and
home tree already destroyed the amateur
Kaya may not be so safe for much longer
spider gets captured by the RDA pretty
early on in Avatar 2. he spends a
majority of the film in their captivity
primarily as a part of his father's
Hunting Party while he clearly despises
his captors and rejoins as Sully's as
soon as possible spider also seems oddly
helpful to the humans at times in
particular he guides them to the hidden
home of the mountain banshees allowing
courage's Squad to acquire mounts why
would spider help his sworn enemies in
this way it's possible that the humans
already knew about the Banshee Nest from
Jake's spying in the first film also
spiders only alternative seems to be an
absolutely brutal form of brain scanning
torture which looks like it might have
killed him if it had been subjected to
much more he does resist helping the
recoms on the reefs when they start
burning Navi Villages so the best
explanation is simply that the poor kid
doesn't have any other choice however
things aren't quite so simple when
Quarry successfully claims as Banshee
spider looks excited he smiles at the
sight of his father soaring through the
sky simply puts this makes no sense
spider has always wanted to be a navi
and he completely despises his father so
why isn't he enraged to seek forage
successfully bond with a mount this
should be a moment of outrage of
indignation that the villain of the
story gets to do something spectacular
the spider can never have unfortunately
we don't get enough reflection on this
moment to fully understand what's going
on
it's no secret that Curie is different
than the other Navi on Pandora she has
an uncanny ability to influence whatever
natural forces are around her fish grass
trees birds all these and more seem to
bend to her well it's as if the very
energy of Pandora flows through her into
everything around her this makes it even
more Curious when after bonding with the
Met kaina's underwater Spirit tree Kiri
has a massive seizure during the bond
she has a vision of a mother and asks
her questions about her father but just
as Grace is about to answer she's yanked
away and kiri's body starts to convulse
Norm claims that the seizure is a result
of epilepsy and that the tree triggered
hallucinations via electrical impulses
in kiri's brain but this is Pandora and
nothing is ever that simple the spirit
tree is supposed to be a strong link to
awar so maybe it's that connection that
causes the seizure Yuri seems to be a
conduit for the power of the planet so
linking with it in such a strong way may
have overloaded her throughout the
original sound at sequel we only get
hints of what life is like on Earth from
what is revealed though it doesn't sound
good Jake says in the first film that
there's no green left on his Homeworld
and general Ardmore says that the Earth
is dying the plans for a colonized
Pandora show how extreme things must be
on Earth with Humanity soon intending to
leave the planet for good however we
still haven't gotten a real look at what
things are like back home supplemental
sources like the mobile game Avatar
Pandora rising and the official
companion book Avatar and activist
Survival Guide offer a few more details
corporate dominance environmental
Devastation and constant Warfare have
effectively decimated Earth's natural
ecosystem by the time the films take
place we also know from a handful of
lines that classism is rampant the super
rich can afford miraculous surgeries and
eternal youth with enough money while
the masses are left to fight for
survival on the planet's desolate hersk
going back to Earth seems
counter-intuitive to what the Avatar
movies excel at which is showing
gorgeous alien locales and exotic animal
animals steal a trip home and a closer
look at her seems inevitable as the
story moves forward
when courage returns to Pandora at the
beginning of Avatar the way of water
he's quickly brought up to speed by
General Ardmore she informs him that the
rda's main objective now is no longer
the mining of unobtainium but the
preparation of Pandora for full human
colonization with the Earth rapidly
dying Pandora looks to be the best
chance Humanity has for a new home of
course that also means ripping the
planets away from its rightful
inhabitants decimating its natural
landscape and being completely vile in
basically every way the humans are
returning they're hunting us the odd
thing is that later in the film we see
another very different part of the rda's
operations the hunting of the Tolkien
the hyper-intelligent whale-like
creatures are valuable for the fluid
extracted from their brains which is
said to stop human aging completely like
an obtainium it's a valuable resource
but not one that would likely benefit
the majority of humans on Earth the RDA
is pretty clearly to face claiming to be
fighting for the survival of the species
or using its immense resources to
further enrich us Elite their
duplicitous nature begs the question who
would actually get to come to Pandora if
it were colonized the masses or just the
ridge propped up by their hoarded wealth
and a healthy number of Navi slaves
Ardmore only has a small role in the way
of water but she'll likely be much more
important and villainous in the
following films one of the main story
lines at Avatar the way of water is the
adorable friendship between loac Jake
and natiri's second son and payakan an
outcast Tolkien who saves his life the
Tolkien has been ostracized by the rest
of his kind for rejecting their strict
policy of pacifism
specifically he led an attack on an RDA
ship after his mother was killed by
humans leading to the deaths of many
other Tolkien and met kaina Navi it's a
tragic story but the timeline of it is
pretty confusing humans only return to
Pandora a year before the events of the
film and as far as we know the rda's
operations during the first film had
nothing to do with the sea that means
that it would have been a year ago at
most subpayakan's mother was killed but
that doesn't really make sense we see
that the Tolkien Hunters Target mothers
with young cows because they won't
abandon their kids while never
explicitly confirmed it's implied that
that's what happened to payakan's mother
and yet he's a full-grown adult maybe he
was already full grown when his mother
was killed but that also creates some
weird discrepancies the Meg kaina talk
about him like he's a legend someone
they grew up hearing stories about so
was Tolkien hunting a thing during the
original Avatar is there something else
going on here or is this just a plot
hole after a long battle with Jake Sully
at the end of Avatar the way of water
for Rich has strangled out and left to
drown of course the unkillable man makes
it out once again this time saved
reluctantly by his son spider doesn't
seek his father out he's looking for the
other sullies when he comes upon
courage's comatose body despite his
hatred for the man he grabs him and
Carries him to the surface allowing him
to fly to safety on the back of his
Banshee why does spider do this well
there are a couple of explanations just
moments prior he was under natiri's
knife who threatened to kill him if
quarries didn't release took in a
surprising twist of fate the villain
agrees showing that he does care for his
son despite his claims to the contrary
in addition to this recent display of
affection spider probably just doesn't
want to be responsible for his father's
death leaving him to drown would
basically be killing him and killing
your father is a big ask even if you
loathe his guts spider hisses at courage
when he's invited to flee with him
choosing instead to rejoin the sullies
however he doesn't tell them what he's
done will quarries continue to torment
the family putting blood on spiders
hands or will this experience cause him
to rethink his heinous ways courage is
about as cartoonish as a movie villain
can possibly get Stephen langa's Master
follows the detestable body spewing
hateful monologues and cheesy one-liners
in the same breath and he adds despite
how over-the-top hateable the character
is there are hints that he could redeem
himself in his first real conversation
with spider crawrich apologizes for
being a bad father something that
doesn't make sense given that he was
killed when his son was just a baby this
whole scene is a pretty obvious
manipulation and he even drops the same
line he used on Jake in the original
film you got some hard kids showing up
in this neighborhood spider doesn't buy
it but he chooses to go with quorwich
rather than be subjected to more of the
rda's torture however by the end of the
movie there's at least a shred of
begrudging loyalty between the two of
them calling it love might be a step too
far but there's something there maybe
spiders hatred of him will be the fuel
that makes courage reflect on his past
actions given all the evil he's done
though full Redemption would be a tall
task at the end of the way of water says
that he inspired there aren't even the
same species and that line has more
meaning than it may seem though he's the
one in a navi body he clearly thinks of
himself as human and his son as
something else nonetheless he surprises
himself and everyone else by actually
begging for spider's life when paiacan
leaves out of the water to attack the
RDA ship at the end of Avatar 2 you
might think that the rest of the Tolkien
are close behind them sure they despise
violence and killing but they'll make an
exception to defend their home right not
exactly fortunately one Tolkien proves
to be enough because payakan's Brethren
never surfaced during the final battle
whether or not they'll change their ways
remains to be seen to be clear there can
absolutely be a role for non-violent
resistors and instances of Oppression
but when the very survival of your
species is on the line that role can be
hard to find humanity isn't gonna stop
their Conquest with a few whales and a
little bit of forest they're coming for
the whole planet and when they do a
whole herd of Tolkien could be a
valuable weapon and the fight for
Freedom May Maybe by account can
convince his community to break their
rules just as once at the very least it
would be nice to see him we admitted
into their ranks the first avatar
doesn't provide a lot of details about
how the Tree of Souls works but the way
of water gives us some interesting new
Clues through the Met kaina's underwater
Spirit tree we see multiple characters
bond with the tree and have curious
Visions however it's still not entirely
clear what they're seeing when Kiri
bonds with the tree she sees her mother
working in a lab the two have a
conversation that's quickly cut off
after Kiri starts asking questions Grace
appears to be yanked away from her and
Kiri starts convulsing from a seizure in
the real world later at the end of the
movie Jake and natiri bonds with the
tree and see their son netiam this
vision is different from curie's because
it appears to be a memory an echo of a
moment at the start of the film that
shows Jake's training that I am to fish
because Kiri never met her mother her
vision couldn't possibly be a memory so
what's happening here are Jake and
natiri actually communing with their
son's spirit is Grace's Soul still alive
in awe as a result of how she died the
spiritual aspects of Pandora may never
be fully explained which isn't a bad
thing but in this case it would be great
to learn a little bit more and Ravi read
their planet of humans at the end of the
original Avatar but things aren't so
simple in the sequel the big action
climax sees the rda's whaling ship
destroyed but Humanity's operations back
in the forest are presumably still going
strong so what's next for the RDA and
how will they respond to the battle on
the reefs if General Ardmore is to be
believed more human forces are coming
she says that she's been sent to tame
this Frontier gesturing to Pandora at
large is to be the new home for Humanity
if the RDA get their way which would
surely Doom the planet with the very
survival of the species apparently at
stake we've likely only seen a fraction
of the military might that's coming the
navi will have a big fight on their
hands of the colonization efforts
continue to gain steam how that fight
takes shape however remains to be seen
could Humanity create a whole Army of
Avatar soldiers to adapt to Pandora's
environment it seems likely could they
stop plundering the spiritual energy of
the planet in addition to his other
natural resources also a possibility the
future looks Grim for the navi but with
a united front they still have a chance
though he's a trained soldier Jake Sully
is Running Scared for most of Avatar the
way of water when he realizes how great
the danger to his children is he
completely abandons his Crusade against
the RDA and dedicates all his energy to
keeping his family safe throughout the
film we see Jake humble himself to the
Mets kaina courage and others to protect
his own but by the end he realizes that
isn't going to cut it anymore Jake saves
in the film's closing narration I can't
save my family by running this suggests
that he's accepted tonawari's invitation
to stay with the mechano rather than
flee again the death of netiam has
changed Jake's perspective and he now
knows that fighting back is the only way
to earn peace however he doesn't give us
many real clues about his next move
let's get it done staying with the Mets
kaina could have some benefits for sure
but so could moving on to yet another
Nabi Clan if the RDA is to be fully
defeated Pandora needs to be United
staying on the Move also isn't a bad
idea and it isn't the same as running
away whatever happens the sullies have
their work cut out for them but they
seem more than up to the task after the
way of water
[Music]